hello welcome to dark gamespot place I'm
Tanya Dwyer not a Spinelli what's going
on hey how are you into a high five yes
absolutely we always start with high
fives yeah we also start with somebody
else sitting beside the driver of the
game today it's you who knows nothing
about mushroom 11 at all no i don't i
have no idea what this game means man
it's perfect so you're gonna act as the
audience basically for this is this is a
game i'm super excited about i played
this at pax for the past couple of years
seem to be at every packs all the
developers kind of rant on about it
loads people here in the office Mary
loves that I know and it came out today
so what we're just gonna show it so I'm
show you for sure why you should like
much me who also is the audience exact
way you are the proxy for the audience
indeed so this is a game as the logo
suggests which is a about this big old
explosion in the back end I think it's
like some sort of weird post-apocalyptic
thing and but it's essentially a puzzle
a 2d puzzle platformer and this is what
you are you were this weird homogeneous
or green bubbly mess what is it's like a
virus of sorts basically move it by just
left click bang on PC deletes this much
and the right legs is a bit more precise
and you basically played the game by
deleting parts of it and watching it
grow on the other side so if i delete
this side it'll like grow it that way or
like top they'll grab bottom or you
basically just sort of trying to
influence us toward something see so I'm
gonna this is the level select so that's
why I become more complicated was later
level I gotta get up there exactly right
that's the thing it's crazy so this is
the first level this is like super
tutorial II and it's been shown a bunch
so we'll just saw just do a little bit
of this and I'll dive into the second
level all right yeah so you basically
sort of like the main thing is you
delete the back as it were and if you
try and get up things you sort of delete
underneath and watch a move along you
can split it in half a few one as well
and basically it like just momentum and
gravity it is you know you just end up
trying to figure I've
heading rules that juice absorb water ya
see that thing serious little thing
uh-huh crazy is it flying it's a little
bug so if you connect these watch the
top left corner when I want to eat this
thing it's kind of like so sort of a
know I'm not sure everybody adds
anything to you but I think it's more of
a because there's like a speedrunning
element to this game so it's also I
think you collecting all of those
they'll insects basically as a you know
like a bonus or something I see when you
turn on one hundred percent the levels
look at it so they're gonna it's
nonsense whoa zayyan speed through those
tunnels flying through it's like super
satisfying and a sort of a sitting
popping pimples kind of way right i say
you know we call we can all do together
I understand that said to be completely
action man uh yeah so this is all like
the kind of world building as well like
like all this like we don't know what's
happened we don't we know what this
thing is I kind of feel bad eating
things because like I feel like I'm just
this weird computer virus that is eating
the last library the little life that
remains exactly and this
post-apocalyptic situation behind me and
these are checkpoints sweet fiber-optic
thing yeah it's like a fiber optic II
kind of digital life in eats organic
life kind of thing and it's a super this
it's like super clever idea for movement
coupled with like very an interesting
level design so like stuff like that
like you come up to and you're like okay
how am I gonna work this out i gotta
push into it and then delete myself out
of it like that's the sort of thing
they're coming up against over and over
again is like all right how does this
weird mechanic how do I get it to work
right so here I'm like I'm stuck where
there's a trigger thing here do you have
a guess what i can do matt is that I'd
have to switch right yeah maybe oh oh
okay go yourself a to do that guy any
influence of true and I got to do that
now it'll be like think of clothes oh I
don't care I'm gonna squeeze through
this thing is it a mess try collect all
these guys looked at some world building
over here looks like your old self feel
brand new umask what's you mask look
there's a DNA thing over here get it
hundred percent this yeah man yeah
commitments back yeah nice eat you up
get a lot of water organism things
whatever that is eat them all um I'm
gonna do a little bit more of this and
we'll spin over to another level but
it's cool it's like it's just the
movement becomes real second nature you
know you're like playing game like
portal do you play portal much a little
bit yeah remember like you played that
game start and kind of sucked at it yeah
that was pretty pretty terrible for ya
then after like a while after a couple
of like levels you just kind of get used
to the feeling of it like right and also
the logic I guess yeah you know which is
the sort of same thing here like we
start to like I don't know like because
this isn't like another 2d platformer
game this is doing something altogether
new like layers nonsense what spin this
thing back then it becomes up stock
today I'm gonna like delete that there
we go huh so the game is like this is
obviously the first level so it gets a
little bit more complicated so maybe
let's have a look at something that's a
little bit more complicated oh not too
much more complicated because I played
my play more on another machine and it
gets pretty tough and I first level I
completed the first time and maybe like
15 16 minutes and then the third level
i'm on now it took me like I think 25 30
so it definitely ups the ante so here
like straight away we got this whole
city we're more complicated yes Ava's
the only thing that really kills you
please like liquids I see so like
everything else is kind of like it takes
the chunks off you like bits of like
flying lava or like enemy projectiles
which we'll see you later and so the
only thing like that'll really reset you
completely is like a pile of liquid if
you fall into that and also this thing
doesn't grow if it's not touching the
ground so if you're flying through the
air and it tends to not grow much at all
oh okay so right now I'm basically just
trying to get my books in here you know
uh-huh some real rules to the logic of
how this proves yeah and it's kind of
like pretty you pick it up pretty
quickly like I fell out to the first
level out a real grasp of what's going
on I see so now we're don't want to do
it's just like dude it's like it's come
forth yes exactly at a certain time you
just have to go for it okay you just
gotta have to be like
this is as far as I'm gonna or you
already do what I do is I'm get like
impatient and then like just completely
fudge it you know right and then
sometimes you just have to like do this
like it's gotta push through you know
just like find your way to the next box
hope to guide you through a kind of like
there's an element of like sometimes you
can plan it out but then sometimes you
just gotta like yolo swaggins your way
through and this is one I just wanna
like get one that's like long enough
sort of I when I delete this is like
reaches up there calm down young man
yeah it's weird like you wouldn't pass
out of work right no no it's just kind
of like you gotta trust a little bit I'm
gonna squeeze through here man oh no
this is like okay I gotta slam this this
is where the gay forgot about that guy
didn't you this is where I like the
momentum sup so if i delete this guy in
the air eyelash not much of it grows
back mm-hmm so I gotta kind of throw it
off this thing and then kind of leave it
alone looks like a cat it does falling
and then here we go and I found it like
there is some like a little bit of
repetition like with steps and stuff but
like generally generally there's a lot
of interesting things they're doing with
like I loved it this part here I love
because the first time I got up here I
couldn't really do it looks like another
kind of thing yeah yeah well I guess
it's like looking at clouds yeah and
then I realized they see that then here
is like a little hook so I just started
sticking myself in there and it helped
me like grow up here a little bit yeah
whichever I'm pretty cool this actually
this is another one of those actually
we're like if you just try and get over
there it's going oh man doesn't work out
but if you get my hook in there and
here if I use this guy it's my advantage
and I get myself in that little crevice
oh and you can kind of like aa little
beggar and then get this guy over looks
like a bunny rabbit now all I'm saying
is I'm listening yeah and then if we do
that we can kind of go just do some
mushroom 11 watching just decipher LBJ
oh [ __ ] oh dude ahahaha God yeah exactly
just like this is a good co-op game
because you can just tell you your buddy
what weird I don't know turning into
every Jewish yeah oh no ok this guy stay
home oh sweet nice you think I'm dad
what up now I'm not quite yet let's add
you fooled let's see that's good this
could to see this area here could have
taken two seconds could take 10 minutes
we'll just have to just have to find out
if I do that I don't eat all that
actually I'm probably take a little bit
of him back and then this is just gonna
c zc he starts growing as waldo so it's
gonna write all rights it do it get over
that guy yeah oh whoa whoa whoa oh sorry
I didn't see that there is a chamber
sorry Sam I didn't see ya I was like hey
just got to the checkpoint get and then
yeah look and then there's i kind of
upped the ante you know to me like it's
so clever like I feel like this is a
game that's been apart for so long and
they like clearly just spent a long time
like ironing this concept a Jew enemy
right cuz feels like a game that's
really been given a lot of like had a
lot of iterative design said you've been
seeing it for a bit like a few years
yeah I feel like maybe three years wow
maybe my mind is saying up because the
amount of pax's that happen over here is
gone up as well so maybe it's said that
ice but I feel like I has I feel like
it's been that long and at the other
various events and every time I've been
there they've been doing a be testing as
well so for those who don't know that's
like when they basically like they have
one terminal which is using a certain
you know game mechanic and then another
one oh [ __ ] which is using a different
one and they watch people playing the
game and then sort of use that to infer
their design I say so it's I think it's
like just a fan
basically well make it look at us just
get up there and go oh whoa i just can i
eat you are you gonna hurt me ooh maybe
I can if I jump up i can hit his red
part maybe they'll all good i'll do it i
just stand up in the middle can you
really do this man I don't know maybe
this is this is the last spider I know
what a good boy killing the last but I
will not be great if that was like the
twist or something right like you just
destroyed everything haha way to go jerk
alright one more puzzle let's try one
more puzzle will bolt it feel like we
can do it got a boulder we got a little
way it's protecting underneath there
let's uh consumer flying things off this
[ __ ] is my favorite thing oh it is not a
sight of up there we could have killed
out her spider but there needs to be too
man hahahahaha why we forgot about that
good point good point well made don't
know if I if I goof what you're doing
here Danny yeah we should tell Russell
who tell this spider about the others
fire and then make a third spider let me
won't feel so bad yeah Oh shouldn't
maybe I thought I would have random
doubt there too yeah that little dude
over here alright let's try it one more
time one more time it's gotta push out a
little further mm-hmm all right and I'd
see what I'm doing is I don't it delete
too much when I go off the edge here
because then it's not gonna be heavy
enough right so I think I want to do
this maybe Rick do that is that gonna do
on come on o son of it hey all right one
more I think that's what I like about it
is that like these puzzles are there are
times when like the first time I did
this it took me maybe five attempts
where are you doing a lot of repetition
I'm gonna use momentum instead and but
it's fun it's like it's a satisfying
process get under get under like
everything its games seems very
meticulously sort of handled in that
sense yeah there's a lot of
entertainment i can imagine can be head
from just keep going at yeah I think
you're right i think that's like it has
been developed with like a fine-tooth
comb kind of thing and yeah like dying
is fun sometimes because it's like on
learning this
right process look at this nonsense like
Jesus brought them what not oh god I
what's with this purpose I got ya the
purple stuff like eats away at you and
more so it's gonna have to be a little
more careful about it and I do this it's
got good I don't to show any more about
game off because I think half the fun is
exploring it and finding out yourself
drew that and what's relevant it's out
on pc mac and linux it's like a steam
plague thing so you buy for one you get
it on all of them oh um it's about i
think it's 1350 and redo that like
person on yeah tever stay first weekday
thing i don't know how long it's on for
but right now anyway it's 1350 $15
otherwise yeah I've been planning for a
couple of hours today and everything try
to me Jack that oh yeah what do you
think first impress a nit super cool i
really like it i haven't really seen
anything like this yeah where's the way
it plays though like control wise it's a
real interesting and technique and I
like that they're not just resting on
that it's actually the level design sort
of works real well right as well as yeah
yeah so we might have a review on
gamespot I don't know yet what I've
asked Peter Brown will Jim yeah we'll
see we'll put in the compass yeah thanks
Matt okay event thanks for watching and
for more mushroom in heaven coverage and
that all your post-apocalyptic needs
stay tuned to gamespot com
you